liebe grüße sind so heutigen sitzungen
heute geht es über das thema künstliche
intelligenz nach der letzten sitzung
unser recht intensiv für unsere
verhältnisse als philosophin und
mit neuronalen künstlichen heute geht es
aber noch irgendetwas weiteres also um
ein weiteres feld nämlich künstliche
intelligenz unrecht allgemeinen sinne
und hier sehen sie das ganze läuft dann
recht schnell schon hinaus auf so ein
roboter und das wird heute auch thema
der sitzung sein welche rolle
solche bewiesen wir haben bereits
zwei zuschauer ein like the counter 15
glaube ich nicht solche nuancen
diese kaufte rechts oben der quote aber
sind gesagt okay also die meute könnte
intelligenz jetzt haben wir zwei und
drei kameras vier likes das wieder
verstanden also künstliche intelligenz
wir haben uns ein mit robotern zu
kriegen
und wir haben trainiert ist übersicht
noch mal dass die 7
die firmen wissen sie noch was die
learning war das ist ein ganz einfach
definierter begriff wie gefährlich das
alles gar nicht sind besondere tiefe
oder so das ist eine ganz einfache
strukturen morgen habe ich genau also
ein renner das netzwerk hat immer einen
input schicht und eine ausgabe schicht
und wenn dann noch ein inzwischen
schlicht das wissen sie noch wie man
diese zwischenschichten das war der
hätten lehrer also die versteckte
schichten mich wieder die rezeption
rezeptoren schicht ist und die eingangs
schicht ich die auskommen sieht immer
nur einer aus der blackbox hat er was
dazwischen von zehn ziemlich und wissen
sie heute braucht und sobald es eben
mehr als diese eingabe ausgabe schicht
sind mehr wird eine oder mehrere
zwischenschichten zu verbinden erst mit
den spielern sprechen die thermik und
ich denke es kommt daher dass eben
sondern künstlich ist nur ganz ganz sehr
viele zwischen hat die auch sehr viel
reputation in einer spalte und aber die
ganze zeit unglaublich komplexen gehen
jetzt für ein ambitionierter auf eine
setzte maße mehr doch recht weit schon
einen um die thematik sehen also hier so
ganz einen ganz kleinen teilnehmer
eigentlich dann ging's mir die größte
menge an der die dieses einschließt der
könnte sich noch jetzt dann gibt es
maschinen lernen und eben die das kann
ich wohne das alles fehlt aber das
breite ausgebaut werden kann
und dann
doch die künstliche intelligenz ganz
keine gnade robotik und so weiter und so
fort bis zum anfassen weiteren bereichen
erzählen
das haben sie gesehen dass es
automatische schrifterkennung also
handschrifterkennung ich kann dann zu
kurz was sagen ich habe also in den
letzten tagen mit ganz geringem aufwand
wahnsinnig viele seiten von deutschlands
englische übersetzen lassen nachdem sie
zuvor mit ocr programm von
frakturschrift und lateinischer schrift
aberkennen
das nimmt mir ungefähr 99 prozent meiner
arbeit haben auch in wissenschaftlichen
editionen dass die zukunft oder diese
programme könnte ich meine arbeit nicht
mehr diesem maße qualitativ und aber
auch geht auf die zeit erledigen das ist
unglaublich und das eine das andere ist
dass hier noch mal dass es hier sehen
sie diese mustererkennung
gesichtserkennung da hat mir sitzen mal
festgestellt dass der computer sehr sie
sich sehr sehr leid tut
wir können sie nicht kennt oder wie man
möchte komplexe recht operationen
durchzuführen also zum beispiel aktionen
oder wurzeln ziehen aber dass sich sehr
schwer tun
solche bilder grafiken muss diesen
kunden muss sind richtig zu
kategorisieren also zb dem linken bild
hier herausfinden dass dessen gesicht
des ganzen wissendes verhindern
das ist zu erkennen
die frage ist ob man es erkennen man
darauf dass man solche fragen sollten
über dem sitzungssaal
das fällt bei einem rechner die herzen
schwer wenn man überhaupt davon sprechen
kann dass ihm schwerfällt oder bier im
sie sehen werden eigentümer dazu solche
kann sich ergänzen und anthropomorphen
blick zu betrachten also wir reden soll
was sie als seien sie subjekte oder
sogar freies objekte und das ist
natürlich problematisch so wie wir auch
dazu nimmt ihre menschliche
eigenschaften zu kommunizieren so neigen
wir dazu entgegenstemmen den menschliche
einschlafen hineinzukommen ziehen und
das müssen wir hinterfragen
hier sehen sie jetzt noch mal das sehen
sie hier noch mal
das ist ein polizist neuronales netz mit
einer info output und einer versteckten
schicht was ist dann zu einem geben
learning system macht und jetzt möchte
ich dann noch mal geholfen an die letzte
sitzung weil es jetzt ein bisschen
komplizierter wurde weil sie sie haben
hier die thematik quelle wikipedia
also kam ich auch die zusammenfassung 1
gemacht haben sie die bekommen von mir
die zusammenfassung der von mir nicht
regelmäßig wöchentlich e mails bekommen
gab ich einfach nochmal schreiben nehme
ich ihnen das
in die verteilerliste auf in der app der
filou gast app können sie das auch noch
auf also ihr seht sie jetzt eingaben
eingabe werte wenn jedes eingang und
dann ziehen sie doch die gewichtungen
die mit jeder eingabe assoziiert wird
darauf sind wir setzte man nur ganz
knapp einig die gewichtungen sind es
entscheidende einem neuen wahlsystem
beide gewichtungen gewisse farben
darstellen
die sie verändern können an den
sicherungen spielen kann als der
lerneffekt eines künstlichen neuronalen
netzes der stehen sich hier in der im
faktor wird x factor der gewichtungen
eines jeweiligen outputs in uns ab da
spielst du mamas in der bürgerhalle
mission zu tun das ist ein signal das
bedeutet alle das ist die summe
alle infos multiplizieren derweil sind
im gewicht
wer agiert dann haben wir hier einen
wert gebildet
und dieser wert wird dann mit
ein gegeben als es wert ist ein ericsson
derweil angegeben
eine aktivierung der emotionen viel und
da haben wir gesagt dass es in der regel
eine siegfried funktioniert deswegen
weil sie so aussehen 1 s beim jetzt
kritisch und man kann auch eine andere
aktivierungs funktion neben entscheiden
ist dafür nur das wohnen geben einen
schwellenwert umsetzen der beschritten
werden muss bevor sich aktive und das
hat folgende vorteile für den sie mal
was ist der vorteil davon dass wohnen
auch die biologische einstellen will ein
aktivierungspotenzial ist jetzt also ist
der vorteil dass wir uns wahrscheinlich
im datenstrom genau so ganz genau an die
7c registrieren nicht alles sind nicht
rezepte alles in nur für einen
bestimmten wert der ein bestimmtes limit
überschreitet wirst dann werden sie
aktiven für die richtig und zu geben
wäre völlig überlastet wenn es auch
alles reagieren würde
das so fortsetzen würden wenn nur der
kleinste im bootcamp
das ist also schon richtungen und so
einen moment funktion macht das ganze
sehr geschmeidig und hatte so eine
natürliche strukturen kann
okay das ist praktisch normal dass china
und jetzt drängen sich hier noch ein
bisschen antrag grafik aus diesem buch
von remy dieses buch altwerden von tarik
schied was ihn zu empfehlen kann
also wie gesagt auch digitale freunde
hinzufügen mit denen kann und hier sehen
sie noch mal eben dx werden wird die
gebilde ist was diese person aus dem
einleben x den verschiebungen die mich
also wie wichtig ihnen der jeweilige
eingang ist und jetzt kommt
entscheidende worauf ich die letzten
sitzung mit ganz kurz zu sprechen kam
das entscheidende messungen
letzte weg könnten diese normales
netzwerk intelligent gemachte könnte
oder wo man von lernen effekt sprechen
könnte ist die sogenannte fehlermeldung
oder 23 ist jetzt ein bisschen
kompliziert erklärte kurz und jetzt
haben jetzt haben wir verschiedene im
gewichtung beziehung dazu
und diese gewichtung sbz gandhis
barriere ist können sie verändern wie
sie wollen
und dann haben sie am ende wenn sie und
beliebige gewicht uns funktion eben
diese ereignisse nicht mehr aussagen und
sie können die ausgabe messen an dem
service
sie könnte die post habe fehler gerecht
ist die differenz zwischen ebenso werden
und faktischen 1 gewannen
und je nachdem wie jetzt diese ausgabe
ferner aussieht speisen weniger also wir
melden sie den zurück und multiplizieren
kämen unterlassen
und zwar immer proportional nach
verhältnis der gewichtung zurück sie
multiplizieren den damit wieder zurück
und das ist letztendlich diese
geschlossene struktur und so können sie
immer wieder wenn sie im ergebnis haben
das prüfen und nina fehler grad
diesen fehler zurückmelden und
dahingehend dann die jungen der
verschiedenen zu ändern und das ganze
systems so austarieren das ist ein ganz
großes austarierung spiel so muss man
sich das vorstellen
mitunter durch viele faktoren weil sie
sehen ja familien gehen zwei aus wenn
ihr auch hier sind und soweit es folgen
jetzt mehrere schichten sind dann kann
sich leicht ausrechnen wie komplex
dieses ganze verzweigung system und das
ganze läuft am ende darauf hinaus dass
angst man schon gehört dass man immer
tritten bildet in der mathematik
matrizen matrizen enthalten dann die
hälfte richtung und wollte bz matratzen
miteinander
am ende wurden sie denn so ein ausgaben
für material
mit diesem gewicht komplexe
mathematische operation und das hier
wissen sie was das hier ist das sieht
wie sieht das große viel ein was ihr das
aus genau
also es geht hier das ist das sogenannte
grad jeden tim verfahren wie geht es
darum irgend jetzt grafisch
eindimensional dargestellt den
geringsten fehler zu bringen einen ganz
komplexen letzten denn der nächste
fehler in diesen tagen und desinfektion
haben ja wir wollen diesen
während sich diese sachen anzustreben
indem er zu schauen wo es der wehr dann
gelesen kann und so könnte es auch bei
dem jetzigen und anschaulichen dispenser
mental wieder eindruck
grund das thema zusammengestellt bei
zeitungen verkauft sind
sie haben hier verschiedene sagen man
hat ihn verschiedene werte sie hatten
den 76 wird ein guter typ solon z
verschiedene faktoren von gewichtungen
wird das halt so eine gewichtung mit
einem gewicht uns beziehung unter dem
motto 2 ich gebe es dann eben diese zwei
diese achse und diese und man kann das
aber noch beliebig weiter an
dimensionieren müssen jetzt neben zwei
während nachdem man sich selbst sind wir
niemanden gewesen fehler sucht und das
wird also ziemlich kompliziert da muss
dann per zelle ableitungen machen an
einem wert nahe anderen und so sieht das
aber jedenfalls kraft aus und lässt sich
einfach nur einen versuch hier in dieses
tages tauchen von dem maximalen fehler
zum geringsten fehler
das ist dieser wert durch diese
einspielung der gewichtung besonders
optimiert wird
ja ja das problem weiter die globale
belebung von lokal zu lokal ist minimum
jetzt so ein kleines tal und es ist
global und das wird schon gelesen hat
ist also recht schwierig zum beispiel
hier sehen sie jetzt noch teenager alter
der muskel führung problemfilm gespielt
das ist als auch mit diesem code voraus
methode das reicht wenn sie das ableiten
wollen seine produktion nach dem minimum
wie in der mathematischen funktion wird
das unglaubliche spiele abzuarbeiten
und deswegen ist ja alles okay
ok also und jetzt möchte ich entscheide
folgen heutigen signals folgende wir
wollen uns jetzt über leben jetzt haben
sie das mal so bewährt die birnen
präsent meinen augen gibt es
fortschrittlichste die
fortschrittlichste an der konferenz
vertreten in die gespräche
und jetzt schauen wir uns mal
verschiedene systemische phänomene bzw
akten angegeben auftreten der welt und
zwar es gibt wir können intelligente
systeme uns eingeschlossen geben einfach
uns aus wir können klassifizieren oder
kategorien
wir können erkennen und dem
entscheidenden wir können lernen wir
können uns etwas mehr können sich
wortgefecht nist wir können vernetzen
oder assoziieren wir können unser etwas
erinnern haben mit dem er kann auch zu
tun
wir können das wissen wir können etwas
verstehen wir können etwas denken oder
an etwas denken intensität wir können
etwas begreifen wir können etwas
vorstellen und entscheiden habe ich
schon roten hinter
auch danach handeln nach unserer
erkenntnis nahezu verschlagen haben sie
noch weitere systemische phänomene als
erkenntnistheoretische domain die sie
selbst besitzen die sie selbst auch mit
das ist nämlich mal eine ziemlich lange
liste mit allen möglichen dingen
probleme sehen kann gut genau also
problematisiert oder bekannter zwar
genau problematisiert als 100 menschen
aber das sind jetzt schon mal sehr viele
sachen und wir uns fragen wer in dieser
akte dass ihr sohn war es handelt sich
hier genau das messer noch mal wärter
angegriffen
wir müssen das definieren und wegen
dieser begriffe oder aktien welche
wiederum treffen auf künstliche normalen
adsense oder auf künstliche grenze wird
ja häufig so leicht davon gesprochen
dass es sich um eine intelligente werden
aber wie wird davon gesprochen dass
künstliche lernen wir haben dieses
feedback ohne dass sie zucker denken
oder dass sie entscheiden dass sie als
entscheiden wie das autofahren und sie
liebt das tesla auto fahren
ob es jetzt links ab wir wollen uns
jetzt fragen treffen diese aktuell 72
aber jetzt habe ich ein zitat von
immanuel kant macht sie nicht sprechen
aber auch ein bisschen auf die klassiker
werbung des urteils kraft überhaupt ist
das vermögen das besondere als enthalten
unter den allgemeinen also müsste so
vorstellen sie haben
einige geben zum beispiel und und haben
uns zum beispiel das thema hier
wir müssen den unterricht
erst besorgen dabei eine als ein
benziner und familie die auch immer
unter die nächst höhere gattung zu
funktionieren also unterzuordnen ist das
allgemeine geregelt das prinzip das
gesetzesprojekt haben und der körper im
begriff ist der gegeben so ist die
urteilskraft welche dass personen dort
im nachbarland rationiert bestimmen dass
die bestimmende und als kraft ist aber
nur das besondere gegeben weil sie das
allgemeine finden sollen
so ist die urteilskraft reflektieren
also jemand mehr als 1000 begriffe von
hund hat der sonntag ist er müsste er
hat schwere müssen sie abstrahiert von
allen ja da müsste schon okay da ist in
sachen um das noch so rund dass er sich
endlich auch das runter aber nicht sagen
dass noch so ein komisches tieren aus
dem fonds ist ein phänomen
und irgendwie ähnlich trist abstrahiert
von diesen wesentlichen eigenschaften
werde dass der kleine ist also zu lösen
nämlich davor nicht kannte und das ist
dem reflektierende und jetzt kann man
sich natürlich fragen besitzt der s 1
906 das ist das bestimmende urteilskraft
würden wir sagen wahrscheinlich ihr also
wir sprachen reflektierte urteilskraft
aber besitzt überhaupt und als gast
sprichwort hat das land überhaupt weil
uns urteilen nummer zurück müsste es
doch eigentlich war früher anwesend ist
begreifen können alles müssen auch
verstehen können
es müssten sie haben eigentlich den sinn
des wortes begreifen verstehen
zur frage ob das notwendig werden aber
jedenfalls kategorisieren kann man
bestürzt
so und jetzt möchte internets wissen sie
was das ist er hat ein neues hemd mir
genau
genau kennt jemand googeln oder ms ganz
neu ich habe jetzt können sich ein neues
smartphone mit
ich kann diese frage nicht das gibt es
seit ein zwei jahren war jetzt die beta
version und jetzt ist es eine funktion
ihres smartphone ihre smartphone kamera
in vielen höher antreten fest jetzt
integriert und das scheint mehr und
somit die spitze der allgemeinen
zuständigen konzerte allgemein
zugänglichen künstlich die gänzlich
zeigen am beispiel das habe ich gestern
gemacht
sie sehen hier ihre smartphone und dass
die kameras ich hatte einmal bücher
hervorgehen liegt und er erkennt sofort
den titelkämpfen die schrift hier ist
und wenn ihr jetzt hier auf den
einkaufswagen clique zeigen wir was das
kostet hatte ich kann mache ich mit der
kamera des handys beliebige gegenstände
in der welt fixieren fokussieren und er
erkennt um was es sich dabei handelt und
wenn das sich unter zeichen handelt
schriftliche zeichen erkennt denn die
als text ich kann es sogar mit dem text
erwähnt papieren kann man direkt
betroffen und ich kann
wie auch mit diesen gebe stand gleich
kaufen ich kann das ganze internet
durchsuchen nachlassen
das ergibt es dass wir auch schon über
produkte genauer zum beispiel gibt es
fox fox ist ein programm wo ich die
kosmetika giftstoffe scannen kann
aber das ist jetzt nicht ob die wirklich
alles in der welt alles geben sich das
sieht fällt klassifizieren und verlinkt
und es scheint mir so gründlich mit die
die nützlichste können sich intelligenz
und anderssein also finde ich das
ziemlich gute funktionen man muss
natürlich sich hier wieder fragen
datenschutz an zunge wenn da jetzt wir
alles registriert fast nicht mit dem
handy mir hier so findet aber ich denke
es muss ja davor schon in der indie da
muss sich davor schon gesammelt werden
das genau ausweisen mehr ausflügler das
sind das heißt es wäre eigentlich ihr
sind bestimmende unterwegs ich habe das
ein
mit müssen wir schauen was fällt mehr
weil diese bestimmte urteilskraft nichts
unterschätzen man muss ja auch fehler
beschließen
hier stellt ein nutzer eine frage es
gibt es von uns menschen bei der
bewertung eines neuen gesetzes einen
unterschied zwischen fraktion und
strukturen kann eine gabi nicht auch
gleichzeitig ein problem zu sein
die funktion struktur und ich weiß jetzt
eben leider nicht was ist ein pc mit
vergeben
also ich würde sowieso immer sagen eine
künstliche netzwerkes sind bestenfalls
zombies ein bisschen ja wesen eben keine
quali haben also die keine subjektiven
zustände eigentlich die aber diese
funktionen eben erfüllen von außen
betrachten diese ganzen inneren zustände
würde ich diesen ganzen jahrhundert
wenn diese künste games absprechen ich
würde sogar so weit gehen
neben den allermeisten solche
systemischen 8 gigawatt zu sprechen und
darüber diskutieren also merken sie sich
nochmal diesel ist sie gut an und wir
wollen jetzt ganz in ihren texten an
oben ein paar texte anschauen und
untersuchen wie die jeweiligen autoren
diese begriffe verwenden und ob sie
privat verwendet
oder analogen oder metaphorisch sind die
salafistischen rede weist also ich
wollte das noch zeigen google es ist
eine sehr sehr gute funktion wie ich
finde ziemlich fortgeschritten weil es
unser sichtfeld so wie wir in die welt
schauen wie wir erkennen ziemlich gut zu
machen
ziemlich seien jetzt habt ihr noch
importe vom letztens verletzten woche in
uns gelungen und so erfolgen dass marcel
belastung auch hingewiesen es gibt
probleme der problemlösungskompetenz als
intelligenz wird biologisch oder auch
psychologisch so definiert dass es die
kompetenz ist die problems rechtsgrund
und sowas ist ein problem geben wir ein
beispiel was ist noch nirgends etwas
kritischen anfragen genau also noch
nicht oder noch wörtlich wieder ein
problem einfach etwas vorliegendes etwas
machst mir vorgeworfen wird als sie es
nicht als argument so war es einfach
mehr im wege steht was da besteht und
ich komme da nicht vorbei das ist
natürlich ein problem was mir da
entgegen geworfen wird
ich komme es getan
eine schwierige situation und die später
so ist für mich unangenehm als
meditation um wohlempfinden und ich muss
mit dieser situation zurechtkommen ich
muss dazu eine lösung dass ich mit der
situation leben
es gibt andere auch es gibt ganz viele
definitionen habe ich glaube im
weitesten sinne kann lust auf unterricht
problem intelligenz ist intelligent ist
da sehen mit derjenigen in die hände
das mit problemen am besten zurechtkommt
man muss einfach definieren was ein
problem ist aber auch da werde ich der
meinung wir müssen jetzt möglichst weit
gefasst
natürlich kann man intelligenz ins kaum
messen sich ungeschützt und eines in
cortez und so weiter so frau aber dass
er sie je nach nico test werden andere
werte gemessen und es gibt verschiedene
tests raymond estin wechsler test also
weiter manche tests und kultur abhängig
und so weiter und so fort
sie wollen ja wenn sie die intelligenz
messen dass mit diesen generell macht
roman anwendung sicher das nicht
versteht was soll ich zum beispiel
wissen akku leer und das wissen der lage
bin das ist dann das sofort nutzen dass
die neuesten artikel diverse mich auch
intrigen ja aber neues ist der 19
als damit etwas anfangen können also
wissen muss sich ja immer mehr an
konkreten situation und deswegen würde
ich wieder dieses problem in einbringt
als man das ganze geld wenn man neues
wissen der wand aber die im wissen auch
immer wissen was angewendet werden kann
und was mir konkret ein vorteil
verspricht
und dieser vorteil damit einher geht der
irgendwie damit dem problem zusammen
weil ich eben bestimmte probleme lösen
kann die vorher so nicht lesen müssen
konnte auch auf emotionen und wenn
nichts und es gibt immer zentrumsnah
emotional in der die jetzt aber das
widerspricht diese differenzierung nicht
weil ich mich wenn ich meine emotionale
intelligenz steigen eben mit anderen
form von problemen sehr gutes recht
kommt zum beispiel zwischen menschen ein
problem wenn du meinen wenn man keine
sensibilität vergrößert wird wenn ich
psychologische strategien besser kenne
mich mit anderen besser hinein
ersetzen kann muss das in form von
emotionalität jetzt und dann werden
andere typen von problemen leicht erlöst
wird also ich denke das ist unstrittig
dass intelligenz problemlösungskompetenz
ist ob es vielleicht allgemeine
definition was ist die frage wann ich
bin sicherlich eine zentrale definition
und jetzt gibt es hier ein problem
natürlich der problemlösungskompetenz
das erkenntnisinteresse oder auch das
problem wird der ganze intelligenz nur
von außen vor getrunken wir sagen
die reserven an das netz der rechnen wir
doch mal hier aus oder gib mir doch
immer die besten musste erkennungswert
speisepläne 2001 was es erkennen soll
wenn es überhaupt erkennen also was ist
gedrückt und das wiederum heißt es jetzt
oder ein anderes gesetz eingesetzt um
eine vorgabe die hier angebracht
jetzt kann man sich fragen kann der
künstler intelligenz etwas aus eigenem
interesse
problematisch sei also besitzt künstlich
es kann künstlichen ein eigenes
interesse oder überhaupt kein interesse
besitzen fast etwas problematisch wird
also kann können sie es noch an das netz
für mich selbst aus wenn es mal mit
einem problem beschäftigt ist lösungen
wirken anders und melden
hier gibt es noch weitere und können wir
das heißt also sie sehen hier gibt es
ganz verschiedene publik von probleme
einheiten auf überhaupt solche aktien
die erkennen und einschätzen künstlichen
zu sprechen können ist die vorgebaute
aus den kategorien gefedert ist und das
andere problem ist ob wenn ein
neuronales netz genug ist und sehr viele
interessante ergebnisse produzieren ob
wir überhaupt bei uns noch dieses
hineindenken können unser in
systemischer zugriff zu diesen ihren
einsätzen hinreichend wie relevant die
übersicht verlieren und wir wissen was
da jetzt in staffel so lese blackbox ist
und wir auch nicht in den köpfen von uns
kann das nicht einstellen
das wäre aus meiner sicht kein problem
das vorgehen dann kommt es damit
ziemlich gut zurecht und zwar besser als
wir mittlerweile in vielen bereichen
aber es muss erst mal so ein problem
vorgegeben bekommen halt und das scheint
mir das entscheidend sein dass das nicht
kann
es scheint mir jedenfalls dass nur
lebendige systeme also wir bewiesen ein
eigenes auto ist selbst
problembewusstsein also auch zum
beispiel tiere die jetzt nicht besonders
intelligent
die haben ein interesse und verdient
können bestimmte situationen des lebens
zu einem problem werden
ameisen zum beispiel wenn sie ameisen
sagen wir etwas vornehmen dann versuchen
sie das zu vermeiden die versuchen einen
anderen weg zu finden sie versuchen
darauf zu reagieren
ob ihr zu arbeiten schon entwickelt
haben oder nicht nur sparen intelligenz
wissen ein system aber sie finden dass
zum beispiel fühlen oder stellen zu
befreien
er habe dem versucht einen futter zu
bekommen wofür sein sterben zu kurz ist
der erste eindruck ein metalldraht den
so beat und dann das unterboden da sieht
man er hat intelligenz
weil ihnen etwas zu problem wurde er
wollte das futter bekommen dass sie beim
central zugegangen der stadt nehmen wenn
ich in form eines theorietest
bewertungen und leitungsnetz können
da zählt für mich nur der bauch der
maschine
ob die maschine eine eigene interne
prozesse fest stellt genau maschine ist
eine ein black boss black box es wird
sehr sehr kompliziert und das ist ein
zusätzliches problem in die ferne
gerechtfertigt sind mentale oder
erkenntnistheoretische prädikate diesem
system zu schreiben
generell auch von der struktur oder ob
er es auch überhaupt erkennen kann
das sind also 28 gewalt treten fragen
das ist meine momentane sich der dinge
junge lebendige system können wir
wirklich von intelligenten vom starken
sprechen bei nur lebendige systemen
eigenes interesse was günstiges exemplar
von außen vorgegeben bekommen
das ist jetzt mal jemand debatte stehe
mir scheint der beste kandidat hat das
leben
lebendiges system zu seiner zeit in
italien systemen in sich abgeschlossen
ähnliche systeme die stellen sind auch
chrysler organismus organismus ist ein
selbst bezüglich system wo der output
wieder in den fokus was sie selbst als
funktionalität ist aber jetzt denken sie
mal das künstliche mal unter dem netz
feedback schleife das sieht ganz ähnlich
aus sie haben am 7 sie haben auch gut
aber der nebenprodukte zum ort von der
aufstrebenden sie sehen das hat auch
eine ähnliche struktur wie diese kreis
zu selbstbezogen bisher apriori also
jetzt alle riders begrifflicher sich
noch nicht sagen würde dass das nicht
irgendwie möglich sein könnte und zwar
deswegen weil es selbst geschlossene
situation ist und das hat leben auf der
basis zu geben
so haben sie noch fragen zu diesem thema
also ist wenn zb auch interessante
fahrten von der hausarbeit aber immer so
ein paar auf den weg geben also köln
computer der hin kennt wie kommen könnte
köln computer lernen können computer
erkennen oder im konzert ergänzen
erkennen
einfach mal abgelaufen diese ganze liste
die ich ihnen hier präsentieren
abklopfen darauf auch für sich anwenden
können auch die höchst entwickelten
künstlichen intelligenzen ich frage mich
ein bisschen ob man braucht auch unter
den namen liter strenger war später klar
sagen dass das überleben ist dran im
leben würde er uns anstatt dass der
wissensstand ist und man überlegt und
deswegen auch mit gewissem sinne von
außen kommt und wir dadurch ist ein
systemfehler kein eigenes interesse
haben sondern gesagt
darüber bin ich denn jedes lebewesen
würde versuchen zu beleben
also redet ja man kann argumentieren
dass das nicht innerhalb des lebens
kommen sondern
ach so wir haben es wäre dann eben die
natur von geben oder die revolution aber
dieses lebewesen hervorgebracht hat als
ich das immer noch als entwerfer tieren
ist würde ich sagen
überlegen sie es meine ergebnisse
neuronales netz wenn sie uns dann in
euro herausnehmen oder wenn sie einen
layer importeur oder hätten lehrer
rausnehmen würde es nicht sich zu
bemerkbar machen
und ja das überleben wird also lass dir
meinen euro oder so also ich das sich
als das andere ich verstehe ich schon
aber ich glaube dass das was sie sagen
gerade lieben es die nervösen schreiben
also wir sind alle produkte der
evolution als lebewesen und gute
evolution gibt vor natur gibt vor das
überleben soll
aber so existieren wir nehmen das in
berlin wollen wie man einen unterschied
gibt es vielleicht beim menschen oder
problem gewesen dass sie zum beispiel
irgendwann sagen können ich steig heraus
ich steige aus dem system der produktion
augusta ich kann mein leben selbst
bestimmen
sogar das
erkennen dass irgendwann ein zustand
erreicht ist wo man diese äußerungen
diese vorgaben der produktion nicht mehr
als vorgabe an sieht sogar ins äußere
dann müsste man aber vor dem
gesichtspunkt der freiheit darüber
urteilen und dann könnte das eigenleben
zur eigenen tests zuzugestehen
aber das ist irgendwann nur sehr wenige
bewiesen also das mit der neuronalen
netzen so wie sie es beschrieben ist
unproblematisch wie kann die jahre
gewichtung funktionen auf null setzen
würde es den würde trotzdem
weiterarbeiten
ja der wird aber immer nur raus kommt
natürlich nicht nur weniger es doch wenn
sie alle gewichtung auf null setzen wird
alles x 0
und dann kommt mir das gesicht in der
hallenhockey
andere verknüpfung definieren also es
ist von daher könnte zumindest also wie
immer man das interpretieren
aber das würde erstmal weiter
funktionieren insbesondere mit den ja ja
also wenn sie zb wenn sie die sich mit
munition habe und dann nur einsetzen
dann wäre ja kämmerer so zu sorgen
dann kenne ich glaube ich 05
das während der 5 auf jeden fall glaube
ich inszenieren würden das ist richtig
aber was wollen sie jetzt bei mit zahlen
also philosophie alles dass das netz
nicht zusammenbricht
also ich habe das so interpretieren wie
es gesagt haben dass das dach sowie das
sagt dann oder das sagt nicht dass mir
lass mir mal meinte meine netze sondern
um einen euro sondern es würde einfach
weiter wie hat nix meint jetzt nicht
folgendes dass sie in die in dem punkt
null eingeben sind der city wohnt
aussehen also nicht nur mit 0 1
die neurone rausnehmen und dass dann das
system irgendwie rückmelden würde meine
existenz wird hier reduziert so was wie
werden sie in einem tier irgendwelche
körperteile abnehmen dann wird sich
dieses tier dagegen wehren aus
natürlichen überleben sind werden sie in
ein netzwerk holen außerdem wird es
darum gehen gar nichts in der wert der
messwert wird am ende schlechter werden
weil es weniger komplexen aber das
können wir nicht interpretieren als ob
jetzt in eigeninteresse an der texas
zerstört und es wird sich auch nicht
regenerieren und schreiben das ist die
aneinander punkt wenn sie den organismus
schädigen repariert ist
wenn sie ihr über eure meinung jetzt
werden künstlichen unserem gehirn
ausgeschlossenen sie da wohnen wegnehmen
könnte sich vielleicht nach bin ich kein
experte aber wenn sie in einem
künstlichen online netzwerk
ferner wird es das nicht regenerierende
aus sich selbst heraus dass man es hat
kein internes vitales interesse sich auf
recht zu haben ist der fehler werte
heraus konkrete also der der feder der
output wird schlechter werden wenn ich
die neuerung draußen weil es weniger
komplex ich habe weniger
spielmöglichkeiten aber das ist
natürlich kein zeichen dafür dass es
überlebende
das meint also sie wenn er mit dem tier
körperlich hier körperlich verlieren
dann wird es ein schutzmechanismus
aufbauen und das würden künftig es nun
alles mit sich machen sagte sie
genau dies müsse definieren wenn das der
fall ist wenn also wäre im monat
reagiere darauf wenn du dies nur und
gekauft ist dann mit bildern neues aus
dem ist sowas aber es wird nicht von
selbst aus sondern überlebensstrategie
entwickelt genau also während künstler
ein lebendiger systeme deutlich die
lebendige miteinander netz geben so eine
regenerierung zu haben das müsste man
sonst
künstliche neuronale netz einspeisen
dann wäre es aber wieder ein heterogenes
bei einem konkurs mit gesetztes
interessen haben sich jetzt fragen ob
die systeme so selbst zu wie wir können
in einem so hohen komplexitätsgrad das
irgendwann daraus so was wie ein
überlebens behaupten lebensinteressen
erwächst das müsste man aber es müsste
dann schon extremst sämtlich sein und
auf eine ganz andere weise als wir
bisher selbstbezüglichkeit dingen
vertraut ist natürlich zukunft haben sie
sonst fragen dazu
wir wissen jetzt nur noch ein paar
anregungen und jetzt kommen wir hier auf
dieses buch zu sprechen von gunther
maassen kann angehen
bei mensch und maschine künstliche
intelligenz und mutter sein leben
verändern kennen sie dieses buch schon
mal für dieses recht princess projekt
verschiedene und ich habe jetzt den fall
weiterer hat unser was bedeutet
künstliche intelligenz überhaupt ohne
liegen die grenzen und potenzialen der
künstler sie die ganze wir sind darauf
bereits eingegangen sind
da man bisher können wir maschinen als
subjekte oder akteure aufpassen
das betrifft wieder diese fragen nach
bei diesen ganzen listen prädikaten die
ich ihnen gezeigt hatte wie viel können
wir ihre operationen kooperation sind
sicherlich als erkennen wissen
entscheiden denken handeln und so weiter
bezeichnen kann einen tesla handel kann
es entscheiden oder sind es nur noch
nicht genannt
andere kommen fische redeweisen also für
verlebendigung vermenschlichung von
toten toten system vitalis tisch
professioneller berlin
lesen werden sprechen einen animismus
wir reden so als ob diese systeme
bisherige zeit passieren meinte mende
gesagt okay und überlegt die problematik
der lkw das ist auch noch nicht der
punkt diskutieren müsste also es hat der
moral verstoßen so alles und kann es im
nächsten gelesen worden
das ist der einstieg könnten in gänze
kann und erlebt gerade ihren kitty hawk
and mccully forschen ergeht es wie den
pionieren des nachtflugs jahrzehnte lang
sind sie immer wieder gescheitert nach
vollmundigen ankündigung ein ums andere
mal abgestürzt doch dann gelingt den
brüdern wright die horde us staaten
aufkommen der durch technologie heben ab
und plötzlich platz was vor wenigen
jahren nur einen gross sprecher vision
behauptet seit rund drei jahren das buch
ist ganz neu bis 2019 schüler 2016
seit rund drei jahren können
computerprogramme menschliche gesichter
deutlich zuverlässiger erkennen als die
meisten menschen
bei der diagnose bestimmte krebszellen
sind rechner heute schon genauer als die
besten ärzte wert geschweige denn als
durchschnittliche ernsten anrufe ins
chaos computer schlagen den menschen
nicht können intuitiv im brettspiel go
was du trinkst der des schwierigsten
komplexes spiel des jahres die zum
komplex es schon seit januar 2007
sie prüfen auch laufen auch besser als
die besten pokerspieler der welt an
japanischen versicherung von total prüft
das ibm system wachsen die
rückerstattung ansprüche der
versicherten bei bridge worte dem
größten hedgefonds der welt entscheiden
algorithmen nicht mit einer investition
ein mit umfangreichen mitarbeiterdaten
gefütterte system wird zum modus erkennt
die wahrscheinlich beste
geschäftsstrategie die beste
zusammensetzung eines teams eine
bestimmte aufgaben und es gibt
empfehlungen zu befördern und entlassen
also das sind wirklich sehr sehr
beeindruckende leistung der künste und
ergänzt die wie mir scheint jetzt eben
neuerdings dort eingang finden wo sie
früher noch nicht denkbar waren und wo
sie neben unserer entscheidung zu
erleichtern
dass wir ihnen fast schon sowas
kontrolliert zu bestehen das sind
jedenfalls ganz komplexe geräte effekte
die hinserie intelligenz für uns
menschen jedenfalls voraussetzen wie man
beim am beispiel eines schachspiels
sieht
[Musik]
fast ein bisschen eine ganz komplett
komplizierte kunst
und wer dort von einem kästchen das
system handelt würde zunächst mal dazu
neigen um eine intrige zu gesprächen
werden sie würde ich sagen hast das zeug
nicht lesen aber weiter kaffee ist die
nächste stufe der automatisierung
schweres gerät erledigt schon seit
langem die schmutzige abfertigungs
reporter wurden seit den sechziger
jahren immer geschickter et system
halfen bis dato vor allem bei den
routine schleifen den wissens
sie erleichtern die buchhaltung rechnen
im auftrag des menschen oder war beim
text doch mit dem künstliche intelligenz
treffen jetzt hat das komplexe
entscheidung die bisher nur menschen
treffen oder dem aufholen wenn
datengrundlage und entscheidungs rahmen
stimmen entscheidet kann ihr system
besser schneller und billiger des
lkw-fahrers abgearbeitet
oder beide manager möchte ich hier auf
eine seite hinweisen nämlich herstellung
von komplexen entscheidungen
das müssen wir als philosophen kritisch
hinterfragen
ja und da steht jetzt dem system einen
mentalen packt entscheidung
befragen sie sind dass entscheidungen
sind das entscheidung was zu behaupten
entscheidung wo wir uns überlegen uns
jetzt mal was wahrscheinlich ist
solche phänomene ausgearbeitet
ja
[Musik]
entscheidend
als dienstagabend einig dass entscheide
mich bedeutet irgend eine münze zu
werfen und sorgen bei kopf- oder zahlen
macht ist es ist es während wehen
könnten
entscheidend ist nicht das entscheidende
geben sie mir nur so eine definition von
kinderkultur leute auswahl von
verschiedenen alternativen also mehrere
man entscheidet sich für eine sache von
gefühlen
[Musik]
zwar können sie die auswahl noch ein
bisschen genauer bestimmen ja also die
brust noch ich haben will und ich habe
ihr ziel darin ziehen
oder ein problem
[Musik]
so und jetzt muss ich abwägen abheben
bezug auf das ziehen und dann komm ich
dass eine auswahl
und dann komme ich eben zwischen
entscheidend ist dass ich wie mein ziel
haben was vorgegeben ist und dass wir
noch das abwägen dass es in können ich
muss ich muss eigentlich wenn ich mich
entscheiden muss ich wenn es nicht
willkür sein soll ist halt irgendwie
gefällt mir
er muss ich gründe eigene den sehr
strengen sind gründe angeben warum das
einem nicht dass an verhält sich dann so
mussten entscheidung oder menschen in
diesem teil betrifft habe jetzt eine
konflikte im grunde dafür hat ja hier
hat man den grund vielleicht nicht ganz
klar
auch jetzt könnt ihr natürlich auch ein
grund sein wirst du mein zu finden ist
auch ein grund denn das nicht mehr eine
christin aber es wäre das wirklich keine
wirkliche rational entscheiden also
lösen
entscheiden sie müssten damit die gründe
dafür barroso zum caritas im nachhinein
könnte man das natürlich sagen nach
einer tagung in der nacht meines lebens
intuitiven und da habe ich aber so
studien herausgefunden hat
da habe ich entscheide die menschen
treffen und haben herausgefunden
menschen
entscheidungen des personals und also
das ist ja gar nicht diese
ungerechtigkeit
na gut
jahr ist es die finanzierung des gibt es
auch aber dann bräuchte ich will nur
folgendes sagen also was ebenfalls
klasse soll die transparenz sollte die b
31 war und man sollte sich auch soll die
exklusiven als man sollte vor wenigen
monaten systeme für mich die dichtungen
wie ich entscheidungen
hoffentlich das mag man das unbewusste
faktoren spielt sich aber wir werden
durchhalten handelt sollte als select
besuchen
maxime haben es so klar und lückenlos zu
machen dass wir jeden schritt und konnte
zudem auf der eingenommen
im bewusstsein faktor eine rolle spielen
kann sein lassen das einlaufen einfach
eine gute entscheidung zeugen wir zu
viele gründe geben wie sie nicht alles
begründen konnte
und ich habe sich ziemlich überschätzt
haben hier gerade jemand rein
geschrieben
entscheidungen sind handeln beschlüsse
auf pass von gründen ich sage nein
den würde ich zustimmen also ist auch
zum abschluss komme von einer tiefen
geben und ich habe verschiedene
möglichkeiten
wenn diese ab und schließe daraus den
abwägungen dem vergleichen diese
verschiedenen möglichkeiten schlieker
mich zum anschluss und kommen zum
ergebnis dass nur diese alternative wir
das ziel und die anderen nicht und zwar
das leben des rates es kann zum beispiel
sein wenn sie mal schauen wenn sie ein
logisches problem haben
logisches problem man kann sich
verhandelt ist es die entscheidung hat
es keine logische mathematische aufgabe
diese lösen geht es darum entscheidung
um auswahl sicherlich aus war sicherlich
werden sie zu sagen soll
es gibt dafür alternativ antworten und
die soll jetzt entscheiden und
entscheidungs ziemlich entscheidend ist
wie ich die richtige lösung ist dann ist
es ganz klar dass hier gründe geben
müssen und zwar ganz rational den nutzer
als ganzes zu bekommen habe aber häufig
ist es so mal
unternehmen haben sie es nicht mit
mathematischen aufgaben zu tun und da
gibt es jetzt vielleicht nicht immer
dieses eine ein deutsch spanischen
kontexten habe ich gar keine diente
unter anrechnung wie richtig wir können
auf verschiedene weisen rechnen wir
können effektive rechnen einem kürzeren
rechenwege kommenden längeren aber am
ende gibt es einigen diese eine lösung
weitere frage
[Musik]
ich kann aber auch aus willkür komplexe
strukturen entwerfen bestimmt bestimmt
und die können bestimmt tragfähig seien
bis zum bestimmen gerade aber ausweg für
entwicklung hat das problem dass william
alltäglich inszenierungs bestanden dass
jedem willkür nicht mehr so streng
argumentiert und so streng und den
abwägt aufeinander abstimmen
nach dem heutigen alltäglichen begriff
der bürger ist unter anderem begriffe
wie und willkürlich in diesem sinne ein
bisschen zufall sehr kontingents dann
kann ich mir natürlich auch ein
komplexes system aufbauen
aber es wird nicht so sein soll kommt
korrekt und konsistent sein und es wird
daher wieder dabei
zusammen wenn ich nicht alles begründet
alles abwägen
es geht letztendlich erscheint mehr
entscheiden gemacht allerdings setzen
muss bestimmte gründe faktoren beziehung
zueinander setzen und da damit muss ich
die entscheidung stützen oder
untermauern das schalten
geputzt und genau das hatte ich sie
übersehen also entweder ich halte mich
warten sie noch
können sie diese these jetzt
unterschreiben oder würden sie wie in
these nicht
ich würde sagen es sind neben davon ab
was wir unter entscheidungen verstehen
wenn wir jetzt also ich würde es so
sagen wenn es jetzt lösungen um lösungen
als mathematischen werden berechenbare
und künstliche intelligenzen
berechenbare löst sondern als um einen
gewünschten soll wenn der erreichte
nutzen als wenn man für das erreichen
des ziels die richtige entscheidung ist
dann entscheidend als wenn ich das so
der verlieren der richtige output das
system funktioniert richtig mir sehr gut
und es kommt die richtige auch
regelmäßig aus wenn ich sagen das ist
entscheidung und dann natürlich dann
entscheidende frage ist glaubt man
dieses dieses system das nur und ein
letztes dass wir jetzt hier
kennengelernt haben ob das die selbst
das ist abwegig
das ist die frage erste gäste beispiel
aus der medizin und zb mehr oder weniger
also gefühl nachgewiesen wurde dass die
diagnosen im schnitt besser sind
aus solchen systemen oder es gibt zum
beispiel vom investmentbanking
der hat's mal vor einiger zeit in new
york zum kurs stiegen und der bund der
eingängige gründe dass algorithmen
miteinander gedealt haben und da
irgendwas in die schieflage gekommen ist
es werden ja einige beispiele dafür
sagen wir mal eine entscheidung sehr
wohl wie gesagt wenn man jetzt sich
ziehen und ihr also zusammen
erreichen des ziels und die korrektheit
des erreichens des ziels zeuge als
richtige entscheidung definieren und
dann in scheiben die sich natürlich
nicht man kann aber natürlich als sagen
wir sollen entscheiden zu definieren
sind dieses lebens lebens und gründen
zum beispiel könnte man sagen diese
feedback schleife
diese autokorrektur das könnten wir wir
formulieren als abwägen von gründen als
zu sagen reflektieren als nachdem es ist
ja oder als schneidet das ist doch eine
grundsätzliche operation des menschen
titel ich versuche etwas
ich merke es klappt zu nicht und
versuche so gut ich überlege mir und
jetzt kommen
warum hat es nicht funktioniert und
diese frage glaube ich stellen sich ein
neuronales netz nicht warum hat es nicht
sonst wird es anders versuchen und zwar
mit mittels des gradienten verfahren
sind in dem einige fehler vor aber es
war nicht nach dem gründungen die frage
jetzt auch mehr diese gründe waren
moderne also habe ich das verstanden
es soll angeblich in der lage sein
zumindestens die fehlerhaften wege und
ich glaube so funktioniert das auch beim
co und weil beim schachspiel viele wege
in zukunft auszuschließen genommen das
ist ja auch durch diese gemälde
funktionen durch die speicherung die
spielen ich glaube aber wir können ich
werde dafür öffentliche entscheidungen
oder auch bestimmung entscheidung recht
weit zu fassen so dass wir sowas nicht
abwägen nämlich brauchen sind dass wir
sie mit fehlerkorrektur mit einbeziehen
und schweine mehr sprich das ist ein
prozess sein muss das ganze prozess
dessen letztlich willkürlich und in
einem weiteren sinne wäre ich durchaus
hoffen dass ganzen entscheidung zu
benennen auch im sinne der bestimmende
brutal auf das klassifizieren
es war das tier am ende unter die frage
ist ja auch noch netzwerke eigenständig
entscheidungen
und wir haben bis jetzt modell das wir
die hinrunde netzwerk ein ziel vorgeben
und das nun dahingehend entscheidet es
sich dann löst sich irgendein problem
man kann es dabei um wieder
unterscheiden und zwar so eine sache die
jetzt kommende allem jene ja weniger
grundbausteine freundin hat kommission
ablehnen sie entscheidungen treffen
sollen
und unser hauptziel
auf dem weg zum hauptziel gibt es aber
ganz viele kleine genommen die wir gar
nicht gestimmt haben sagt wollny einfach
auftreten netzwerke und das ist jetzt
die frage eigenständig kabel ich schon
sagen sie zeigen zum beispiel ganz viele
mögliche lösen schritte auf dieses netz
wird so austariert dass wände ganz
verschiedene lösungsstrategie getroffen
werden oder lösungswege ich denke
lösungswege kann man wirklich sagen
aufzeichnen kann
wir haben ausgiebig ausgangs geworden so
war jetzt gibt es hier
diesen weg in diesem weg und wenn es
gibt diesen
und das system diese verschiedenen
lösungsweg beschreitet das schalten wir
nun aus eine elementare form von
intelligenz schulen zu sagen dass alle
lösungswege lösungsstrategien erhoffen
den gibt so auf dieser ebene könnte mir
wirklich noch viele sprechen
wie gesagt unter der bedingung dass das
ziel von groß weil die frage nach dem
warum filter immer noch genau diese
dieses jahr ca das ist für einen verein
system etwas von interesse ist dass es
den zweck verfolgt aus dem inneren und
wie wir als lebewesen den zweck
verfolgen zu überleben
die wir dem zweck verfolgen deine
nahrung zu für uns zu geschaffen das
neuronale systeme nicht sagen jetzt
ziehe ich den stecker aus der steckdose
aus
der premier nicht in lebenssaft
absetzungen mittels unterscheiden sie
sich
zum kunden sagen ich verstehe das ja
eher so dass beim menschen
die gründe sind der eigentliche abriss
erfahrungswerte
das heißt wir haben ähnliche erfahrungen
macht als dünger oder erwärmt menschen
und versucht diesen zu agieren und den
weg um selbst zu arbeiten dagegen wir
entscheiden und es zeichnet sich ein
das ist rechnet
familienleben handschrift und das
instrument besucht das genauso
und herr ansprechen genau so könnte man
es sehen
so könnte man größte selbst fasse es
dann hätte man es ja auch mit dem zu tun
ist eben wieder die frage wie man
gründete steht zum beispiel kam
es besteht also ein grund ist eben etwas
was bezogen auf meinen spezifisches
individuelles interesse von relevant ist
von wellness und sowas hat es ziemlichen
spezifischen die duelle sind es zum
beispiel werden die mir für 17 gründen
unverantwortlich zu gründen allein
aufrecht und deswegen und der deswegen
weil sie derjenige gelten sind oder für
mich etwas links ein grund eben beides
ohrring ich bin weil ich eben meine
individualität darin hin exemplifiziert
ausdrücke durch gewisse interessen für
mich als unternehmer bares im video
mouse zu so dass es niemand in die für
mich relevant wird wie man die dinge
medien
jetzt kann ich vielleicht wieder sagen
gut meine unterwegs waren
und eben jetzt endlich auch mit der
terminiert ist doch eine bestimmte summe
von faktor
und genauso komplex kann das auch machen
das unter wechselt auch weil so viele
termine da einfließen
das ist wieder verlässt bestimmte dinge
nur zu gründen werde die entscheidung
scheint mir aber die freiheit zu sein
und jede installation wirklich vitales
interesse also man könnte ihn immer noch
sagen
ein grund könnten ein interesse ist
problem mit und dann kann natürlich
immer wieder zumindest nach den jetzt
keinen grund zu sprechen aber wenn wir
wie gesagt viele gründe leute verstehen
genauso in der entscheidung weiter
verstehen könnten dann schon würden sie
die entscheidungsprozesse und es
passiert am ausgangspunkt in drei
verschiedenen noch ihnen würden sie das
essen auch dem umstand dass im
zeitfahren
also erstmal nicht gesehen weil das ziel
von außen kommt also dass der erste
bedingung das ziel von ihnen autonomie
ist
selbst gesetzgeber oder selbst ziel oder
sechs sitze und dieses ziel dass es auch
nicht vom ausgangspunkt für vorgegeben
von die medien das neue plätzen
trainiert dann mit daten füttern
das ist aber punkten weiter gratis
man könnte diese daten fütterungen mit
stoffwechsel förderlich um auf der alu
stoffwechsels ist das neuronale netz ist
angewiesen darauf dass man das mit daten
füttern
es kann natürlich wieder voran gut wenn
man es eben ein bietet ein system so wie
wir als serienauto systems sind unter
10.000 euro ansetzt information heraus
ziehen und zu hören ist klar aber ich
glaube eben wie gesagt nicht dass es bei
interesse entwickelt würde endlich neue
informationsbereiche ein zu vermeiden
sagt ja wir müssen die informationen
geben aber es wird sie nicht nur zu weil
es nicht technologisches zweck haft
adressen hat und das glaube ich wenn ich
bedingung dafür dass der strengsten sind
diese
momentan aktiv zustand kann dass ein
teil ist interesse ausbildung und auf
den fast auch internationale politik an
dem kein cent ihre richtigkeit hin
kommen und gerichtet hat intensität ist
das merkmal des geistes geschlecht hin
dass man mental auf phänomene überhaupt
zuschauen kann muss heißt eingerichtet
hat und interesse und es scheint mir so
dass die regionale netze die künstlich
nicht gerichtet sind und dass sie ihm
ausgerichtet es sind also dass die
gewisse weise interessiert werden aber
sie selbst kein und ernennt richtung
besitzen eine ausrichtung und vom außen
ein aus richtung also ich würde sagen
eine relative autonomie besitzen sie
eine relative ende erzählte gesetzt ist
dann können sie ziemlich eigenständig
dem auch mit dem besten weg finden sind
ein starkes team und das war auch eine
so komplexe weise dass wir diese
einzelnen schritte wahrscheinlich gar
nicht mehr nachvollziehen können und
dass ich vielleicht eine eigendynamik
entwickelt wie wir jetzt bei gott sehen
wenn es spielen wo eben der mensch nicht
mehr mithalten kann aber eben unter der
bedingung dass sind
23 wenn sie aber ich würde sagen der
regeln der folgende satz da wenn daten
scheidungsraten stimmen
die qualität der algorithmus einfach
besser in dem sinne wir dastehen und es
das menschliche denken ändern davon ab
dass die grundlage den möchte die von
datengrundlage sprechen und der
entscheidungs rahmen einfach erheblich
komplexer ist als bei was man
künstlicher intelligenz ein verleiten
kann im moment noch genau dies eine
frage ob sich das nicht noch jemand
ändern kann oder ob es nicht bloß
kontingente zufällige situation ist die
qualitativ überboten werden kann was
vornehmlich die unterscheidung zwischen
quantität und qualität ab wann schlägt
die quantität und qualität
wir sehen das programm die blue kennen
sie noch das waren 96 gegen castro in
einem berechneten und der war gar nicht
so intelligent weil da haben die
ingenieure die wissenschaftler haben in
der pause vor dem nächsten spiel neue
strategien ein programm
die haben demnach geworfen die haben da
die hatten vergessen paar eröffnung sind
züge 1 programm
nach eindruck und zwar aber es war schon
ein wichtiger schritt aber wenn wir
jetzt eben diese diese tatsache sehen
dass diese programme glücklich wenn wir
eben eine gewisse daten grundlage bieten
die so komplex durchspielen und
vernetzen was ja an sven gantzkow kanton
vernetzen in beziehung setzen dann ist
das glaube ich schon viel er will auch
was die muster erkennen
[Musik]
seit 1960 hat kein system fogra wird
gefördert
deswegen ist es ja genau
aber festgestellt damit können wir
kennen und erlebt oder damit könnten
zweite ganze welt aber wir können keine
künstliche intelligenz und haben
aufgehört und dann bis auf ersten beim
umstellen
jahren das war zwanzig jahre später
technologisch möglich dass sie mir
wieder eingestiegen musste erklärt der
blogger bei mir
dieser behandelt und setzt also das
spiel nachdem zwei punkte endlich fertig
die musste erkennen und dann kann mit
dem wissens- prozess- und die kategorien
ich denke es müsste man doch besser
unterscheiden werde das thema netzwerke
von den tönen kann man der welt das geht
genau als neuronalen netzes sind
jedenfalls solche kategorisierung
systeme die die schaffen es ihr
stückchen umsatz unterzuordnen dem
gelähmtes ihr das denken
also unter senken verstehe ich
eigentlich eine in der selbst
kommunikation denken bereich glauben ja
oder mit gefälligen kalkulierenden welt
existieren denken zu können
das ist aber überhaupt
also sie sehen jetzt kommen neue begriff
aber ich wollte hier auch alles ist man
nur zusammen eben nicht trennen
das ist jetzt mein ganz war es europa
verschieben
das system ist war als nur das system
des entscheides so die
entscheidungsprozesse entscheidung den
kann man schon dort sehen aber denken
wird eben spielen der mit sehr viel an
steigungsstrecken entscheidung kann man
sagen im weitesten sinne urteilskraft
oder bestimmenden und als graf musste
erkennung ist ein konkreten fragen und
etwas zu subsumieren
das kriegt antwort und ich kann dir
richtig kategorie
das ist eine frage von details kraft von
bestimmender und hans kraft von
erkenntnis im weitesten sinne die chance
es wird etwas richtig ein verhältnis
gebracht das ist musste kennen hingehen
jetzt denken das ist normal wie viel
komplexer
denn ist immer ein urteil
immanuel kant im denken als urteile also
alles in ein verhältnis jetzt
angegriffen und dann muss man sie jetzt
waren das ist ein begriff
das sind natürlich auch muster begriffe
aber sind sehr komplexe muster ein
begriff ist nicht nur sohn muss davon
oder katzen katzen gesichert sondern im
begriff hat
das feld und assoziationen von
spielabend ausgeschlossen
ja genau und ein begriff richtigen
angriff könnte der logische verhältnisse
gesetz zu anderen begriffen
wenn es also noch eine viel komplexere
strukturen
das kannst was du isst in antigua
bedeutungs leben müsste erkennung ist
keine bedeutung da ist nix man einfach
nur den karts funktion habe ein computer
erfasst bedeutung
das muss ich nicht erkannt richtigen
zuordnung treffen aber damit heute habe
ich noch nicht die für deutschland zum
beispiel von katz lang oder von gesicht
wenn er dem gesicht der richtig erkennt
also das ist eine semantisch ebene ist
meine kenntnis noch gar nicht mit
erkenntnis scheint mir so ein geiles und
dementieren
das richtige zu wobei denken wird es
dann schon vier spielen wenn wir die
systemische leben entsprechen könnten
wir sagen und künstliche intelligenz
schaffen des abbaus der natürlich
abgingen
ja vielleicht so dass es neben von außen
kommt mal so wir müssen eben begrenzt
informieren wir müssen sie ansetzen wir
müssen regieren und das ist wiederum was
was du nicht von selbst kommt von außen
genau dies hatte sie es mit dem kurs der
internationalität
gesehen das ist mein letztes spiel ist
und was spricht dagegen den menschen
auch alles was ihr dazu sehen wir diesen
punkt ist die senden an das komitee
derzeitigen mensch ist eigentlich auch
nur sehr selten gespieltes kannst dich
nur wenn alles nichts oder direkt hier
kommt eben doch was den zufahrtsweg war
hier zb diese wie zustände wie es ist
eine beleidigung oder einen bestimmten
zustand zu sein und dass dieses wie es
ist auch eine kausale nur kraft hat
sagen die relevanz wie es ist zunächst
ausgeblieben auszusagen genau dass
thomas nagel ist also diese revolution
und das kann eben wie mir scheint
solchen systemen die nur drei jahre
eingespielt sind noch nicht zu sparen
neben unterschlagen viele zb freiheit da
kann man natürlich sagen wir sehen wie
frei ok könnte man sagen aber so was wie
autorin diese gehöre selbst entsetzt da
könnten sie wieder so sind wir einfach
prädestiniert könnte man sagen
also wir sind gar nicht von innen heraus
zielgerichtet sondern das hat uns die
natur oder flogen
da wenn man gibt den menschen so sieht
dann schon aber das scheint eben doch
ein bisschen reduktionistischen zum
beispiel auch so was wie subjektivität
wer weiterkommt subjektivität wie auch
der wusste sein phänomenales bewusstsein
und sein plus qual hier haben was ja
bewusstsein betrifft so was
erscheinenden zeitpunkt noch nicht
enthalten ist natürlich kann man jetzt
sagen wir wissen doch gar nicht was da
im vorgestern im black box soll er jetzt
vielleicht treten wir das umfeld aus
aber solche phänomene müssten dann von
casal wirksam ist es ein karussell
dingfest machen können und dafür haben
wir noch keine
es geht immer um kausalität wenn wir
unter logisch sondern musste sich total
bemerkt haben jetzt ein neuer faktor
genau das haben hier also einiges genau
jetzt geht es um die chance und risiko
das möchte ich so ein bisschen das er
fragt zu recht was ist künstliche
intelligenz überhaupt was kann sie heute
in absehbarer zeit und welche
fähigkeiten musste mich weiterentwickeln
wenn maschine intelligenter werden und
den menschen müsse durch flügeln sich
anschicken darum gehen dieses boot und
dass ich deswegen morgen sind die
menschen flügel und das ist natürlich
die grundsatzfrage besteht diese gefahr
haupt dass die den menschen den flügel
ich denke dass er schuld so ein
bruderschaft spieler wird sich ärgern
wenn partiell männer lieben besiegt wird
und dass
glücklich ich glaube diese diese
schachcomputer und sie kennen ja die eu
zahlen
die zahlen sind diese ranglistenpunkte
und so diese besten schaffen oder die
jetzt auch über künstliche intelligenz
künstliches netzwerksysteme trainiert
worden und zwar auch modelle von vier
stunden hat sich das system das so ein
selbst war das ganze spielt die haben
die region 3000 und 3300 höher als die
besten spieler zu 3000 also 27 und 28
ist ziemlich da ist man richtig werden
dass jemand diese elo zahl hat und die
handlung die 3000 den gewichtigsten
einschalten und musik gemacht haben das
sind 18
richtig platziert genug eine generelle
oder nur kabel nicht lokal global und
hier muss mit dem familien mit den
menschen und muss sagen solange diese
szene nicht von ihren gewissen
zielgruppe selbst in den verkehr wenn
das sie immer noch den außen gesamtmasse
erreichen wir das sagen dann wird es
eben sehr gut erreicht als dieser innere
prozesse der ist perfekt oder der es
besser dass er das mannschaftlich vom
ausgangsposition ziel zu kommen lässt
sich die kritik der geldsysteme besser
ist aber sie können mich von sich selbst
einsetzen von bildern heraus weil es
keine im plenum musste das ist sie nicht
global zum kunden sondern relativ zu
problems möchten können sie hier in
diesen zwischenschritt verschiedene
lösungswege möglich sein werden zur
gleichen problem wie komme ich am
schnellsten zu ziehen
oder wenn ich jetzt hin bestimmte
gegebenheiten haben hinten nicht im
westen
und das geld tatsächlich als ein
relatives problem bezeichnet den
schnellste lösung zu finden
aber das ist ein relatives interesse war
es immer einiges von dem globalen
interesse ins eck auf das sind dieses
system ausgelegt
das system wird sich nicht von selbst
habe auf mein ganzes quälen aussicht das
musste man nur von außen gegeben werden
und damit scheine mehr die sache zu
stehen zu fallen
ob eine interne autonome aus richtung
also solche künstliche neuronale netze
möglich sein
da sehe ich aber noch qualitative
unterschied zu den bisherigen
anwendungen und dann kann man sich
natürlich vor allem welchen normativen
moralischen konsequenzen hatte
stellen sie sich vor neben in manchen
bereichen spezialisiert und bereichen
wie zb taxi fahren weil wir brauchen
vielleicht bald eine taxifahrerin und
frack sie fordern mehr weil diese autos
fahren und sich viel besser im
feierabendverkehr orientieren als ist
jeder mensch steht da werden viele tag
sie haben einen kontakt in förderungen
und stücken arbeiten denn die frage ist
man welches arbeiten können solche
systeme übernehmen und würden wir uns
diesen systemen vertraut
sie habe mitbekommen es gab vor kurzem
ist und unfall des autos
das systems nur ein anderes an das auto
nicht erkannt wurde auf konten in
verschiedenen konstellationen
also das ist eine politische frage die
wahrnehmung anderer haften auch eine
juristische frage genau auf die kommen
wir auch zu sprechen in der weiteren
saison
damit spürt man ganz kurz sie nicht
vergessen dass vielleicht ein altes
bonmot in der country forschung lautet
maschinen fans leiden was menschen
schwer fällt und umgekippt autofahren
mit seinen arbeit tausenden kleinen aber
dennoch komplexen
entscheidungssituationen während einer
vater computern bisher nicht möglich
aber ändert sich das gerade abstrakt
gesprochen lautet die antwort weil aus
daten lernen dass software in verbindung
mit steuerung ist der gehalt mit dem
dreischritt von der canon erkenntnis und
umsetzung eine handlung immer besser
herrschaften hier möchte ich jetzt
natürlich wiederum mache hier in hamburg
ist das wirklich in der handlung ja eine
handlung muss sagen es immer etwas was
ein ziel ein zweck verfolgt allerhand
anderen heißt teleologische sec
ausgerichtet und zwar in der regel aus
eigenen land und das wird er eigentlich
es ist also nur eine relative handelt
sagt immer unter dem aspekt des relativ
dann wäre ich bereit als für das oft
diese ganzen prädikate zuzulassen
relativ gesehen gegeben dass dieser
zweck von außen gesetzt es gibt es eine
erkennung des gibson erkennen und gibt
es hier
behandlung vielleicht hatten sie waren
sehr gerne geben zum beispiel hält
gelingen müssen verschiedene
möglichkeiten aufzeigen
genau das wäre die frage genau also wenn
man jetzt der ziele im leben geld
verdienen oder maxi die
gewinnmaximierung und dann könnte das er
wäre die pause
team vielleicht sogar qualitativ neue
wege indem diese gewinn zu maximieren
ich denke dass wir genau so groß dass
die elfen gehen haben wir auch durch das
reich der elfen mit dem posieren
überlegen nach kauf sollten hier aber
dieses ziel gilt zudem mehr von außen
gegeben
es hat der montag besserem ewige folgen
dieses gibt aber das ist geld das geld
gewinn maximiert sollten wir von außen
mit
das ist nicht von ihm selbst drin
neuronales netz dann könnte ich es
wirklich von selbst aus dann versuchen
geld zu machen oder bitcoins zu hören
das wird es nicht mehr haben werden
deshalb aber wenn ich ihm sage mach doch
mal hier gewinnmaximierung
dann wird es wahrscheinlich erstaunliche
wege aufzeigen auf die ich nicht selbst
gekommen wäre
innerhalb dieses zwecks die
verschiedenen medien zitiert
da wird es mit wahrscheinlich qualitativ
neue wege aufzeigen auf die ich nicht
gekommen
und das ist glaube ich guter kompromiss
zu sagen global oder generell gibt es
keine entscheidung also den höchsten
sind aber regional relativ gesehen gibt
es entstanden unter diesem gesetz zu ich
finde dass für den jetzigen diskussion
stand gekommen
relativ gesehen hat absolut ließen den
können immer nur relativ gesehen von
solchen erkenntnistheoretischen akten
sprechen unter dem wir von außen sind
dass es nichts dann könnte auch in eine
kleinere erstaunlichen nehmerqualitäten
selbst meint wie die burg ich fass es
noch mal zusammen der zusammenfassung
ist so nach der mercedes gesehen und
jetzt sagt hannah situationen regel und
erfahrung leitet das system eine
erkenntnis ab nämlich die beste
möglichkeit aus vielen errechnet waren
szenarien einen unfall zu vermeiden und
dennoch zügig fahren so wichtig die
situation regeln erfahrung aber ein
fehler da ist nach fehlern nämlich dem
zweck und sagen wir müssen sie eben noch
einen zweck vorgeben das vergisst jetzt
der autor hier situation regelt
erfahrung alles klar dass diese aus
nahdistanz
aber der insekten an der böschung
ausgegeben das wird die wir glaube ich
nicht berücksichtigen und zwar den
lösung mit gegeben
die lösung als formuliert und österreich
ist im lebens können durchaus als
entscheidungen fraktion aber eben nur
unter dem gesichtspunkt das ist das
problem von außen vorgegeben ist das 900
netzwerk hat kein eigeninteresse und
kann eigentlich kannst du dir vorstellen
dass eines netzwerks weg vorgegeben
bekommt und dann aber irgendwann sind
mit einem grund der anderen zweck
verfolgen würde
ich glaube ich eben momentan nicht und
bisher immer die frage das ist die
entscheidende frage
zum beispiel dass das system und männern
dieser effekt ist sinnlos wir sollten
bei diesen zweck vertrieben
das wäre für mich wirklich und
religiöser das wäre also wirklich
absolute intelligentes und das andere
auch wenn der zweck noch so dumme ist
wird das system sich daran tod rissen
eben relativ
es hat keine kritische reflexion auf den
zweck das reflektiert nicht die
vorgegebenen zwecke kritisch das hat
kein selbstbewusstsein das habe er
menschliche können alle zwecke die uns
gehen werden kritisch nochmal evaluieren
auch sowie werte normativität bewährt
hier gibt es nun geht es um quantität
wie schnell und elegant comics den
zitaten und dass sie wieder optimal aber
das ist eigentlich nur quantitativ im
starken es in den container qualität gar
nicht rein und dass uns das mit
normativen zum beispiel dazu dem system
sage rechnen wer aus welchen glückliche
menschen töten kann und es nur künstlich
nur und jetzt sagt nein nicht für einen
menschen ein bisschen politisch mache
ich nicht mit dem entscheidet mich und
zwar aus gründen aus dem normativen
konnten ich habe abgewogen ich kann das
im voranschlag veränderungen
das sind natürlich noch mal ganz andere
gründe geben jedes system zu tun was man
sagt eben die menschheit möglichst
effizient schön aber jetzt gehen wir
weiter von diesen fantasien und zwar
jetzt geht es hier noch ganz klassisch
ein kombinierter gehört wir brauchen
jetzt ein digitales buch
wir haben als sonst werden diese
neuronalen systemen ganz bösen und jetzt
hat hier kreml hinter hier wird eine
ethik für das zeit braucht ich möchte
dass zustimmen aber auch kritisch noch
ein bisschen diskutieren
er sagt jetzt warum künstliche
intelligenz nicht nicht denken können
er hat das argument
computer und menschen denken nicht auf
die gleiche weise oder um es zu
präzisieren
ein computer denkt in unseren zellen
überhaupt nicht im grunde müssten schon
angesichts auffällige unterschiede
zwischen künstlicher menschliche
intelligenz klar sein dass computer zwar
denken erfolgreich simulieren ja viele
menschliche denken wenn er zum beispiel
algebraischen formation high präziser
und schneller verarbeiten können als
menschen das beginnt schon beim
taschenrechner aber trotz diese oft
perfektion dem computer computer kein
eigenes beständiges erfassen kann
unternehmen bewusst seien keine einsicht
zu kommen
ich stimme ihnen teilweise zuge der
probleme musste dies aber ich glaube ich
habe nie darum die märkte zu wenig neue
künstliche neuronale netze
berücksichtigt einen taschenrechner
haben wir gesehen dass es nicht denken
das ist nicht intelligent aber lösungs
optimierung optimierung im system glaube
ich habe schon mit intelligenz zu tun
ich glaube auch nicht dass es nur eine
simulation ist jetzt natürlich frage was
simulation aber glaube es gibt hier
schon ist kulturelle identität
mit schweden funktionen mit
rückgewinnungssystem das scheint mit
doch wesentlich mehr menschen zu zeigen
neben als zum taschenrechner ist
deswegen würde ich sagen es gibt hier
schon die skulptur cannelloni neuronale
netz welt der künstler sind im gehirn
märkte bildet die imitieren das gutes
simulation sagte hier auch aber ich
denke es gibt eine größere strukturelle
mehr als herrin 43 das ziel anzugeben
da stellt sich allerdings die frage was
eigentlich den kategorien realen
unterschied aus nach zwischen der bloßen
anwendungen algorithmen gesteuerte
verfahren etwa bisheriger erkenntnis
software photo übersetzungs bekommt und
dem abfassen von bedeutung um zu
erklären was hier mit gemeinde hälfte
aus oder die mathematik und logik der
30er jahre
und dieser zeit entwickelte kurt gödel
ein unternehmen das bis heute als das
wichtigste ergebnis der fall damit man
die mathematik
die grundlöhne sieht es so aus dass ich
kein vielleicht das morgen vollständig
ganz theorien
darauf stellt sich jetzt hier der
wimmeln dieses team sagt dass es waren
um geschirr mathematisches gibt die
szene nicht berechenbar sicher als es
kein argument nietzsches verfahren gibt
dass es dann auch die richtigkeit
beweisen
damit ist die annahme dass ein
algorithmus geben können
wer das menschliche denken als ganzes
repräsentieren könnte als falsch
erwiesen
das heißt keineswegs dass es nicht
möglich sein die richtigkeit unserer
freiheit von den containern überzeugt
das heißt lediglich dass es keine
algorithmus gibt jetzt diese überprüfung
ab wir müssen schon zählt denke wir
können nur diejenigen ausschnitte unsere
entscheidungspraxis an computer oder von
computern gesteuerte roboter definieren
die sich durch den algorithmen
nachbilden lassen
würden sie sagen dass ein künstliches
aroma des nächsten letzt algorithmisch
funktioniert bin mir nicht sicher ich
glaube ich nicht kürzlich ist als
letztes kann algorithmus glaubt auch
noch unterstrich dass in algorithmisch
was aber nicht künstlich bei dem
schatten gestellt werden
aber konzentriert hat genau das glaube
ich auch und da kommt jetzt eine ganz
neue formen und wie geht es im relativen
single schönheit wenn wir statt ich
machen werde
ziemlich genau wissen er unterscheidet
die grünen bisher streit zwischen dem
burschen da ja nur euch den rest
in der emotionalen minute gab es keine
antwort mehr gibt und deshalb und nur
über das so genannte symbiotisch liebe
es sagt alles aus über denken woher
kenne und liebe muss oberhalb des
jüdischen lebens dass das glaube ich
auch kannst du hier scheinen auch ein
passant system muss man hier nicht lesen
das noch mal vor dass theorien der
unberechenbarkeit von kohle zeit und so
dass die dass die welt der logische
mathematische strukturen insgesamt nicht
algorithmischen konturiert ist
menschliche vernunft die menschliche
fähigkeit neue entscheidung und ihre
einstellungen zu begründen und auf die
sekunde lang kohärentes weltbild und
eine korrekte praxis zu entwickeln lässt
sich nicht im modell eines digitalen
computer zu fassen aber vielleicht
wieder im sinne eines künstlichen
neuronalen netzes es wird nie gelingen
die komplexität unserer lebenswelt
begründung
runde vollständig mit adäquater weise
formale zu erfassen
roboter sind sorgt west und ost software
system vom zehner einem rhythmus
menschen nicht gerade liegt 1 1 und 1 1
prozent gestiegen
ja ich würde sagen halt man darf es
nicht nur algorithmisch sehen sind
sollte auch wirklich ganz komplexen
verzweigungen der neuronalen netze der
künstlichen berücksichtigen
er verbringt jedes beiden mit go und so
weiter das ist richtig bedeutet der
übergang von software systemen die ihre
leistung durch das ausrechnen einer
gewaltigen vielfalt mögliche
konstellationen beziehen das system
selbst lernen oft und vorgegebene regeln
rosenheim geregelt entwickelt das
künstliche intelligenz ab diesem
zeitpunkt menschlichsten nicht nur
simuliert sondern auch selbst als
gemeines denkt portiert werden soll ich
würde auch sagen dass reichen und nicht
habe es gibt doch gewisse analogien und
zwar regionale analogie
es geht es hier der ausdruck neuronale
netze ist aber in doppelter hinsicht
erstens bestehen diese netz nicht
ausruhen sondern aus leiter strukturen
und zweigen zählen diese netze
allenfalls sehr entfernt den ganzen
komplexität und plastizität des
menschlichen gehirns
da das funktionieren der vidal
neuronalen netzes menschlich kennt noch
ganz unzureichend erfasst ist kann auch
nicht die rede davon sein dass die
computertechnik menschliche denken
vorgänger bzw
eine realisierung imitiert ich würde
schon sagen mit dieser schwellenwert
funktion wird schon mehr auch wirklich
analog hier erreicht also das scheint
mir schon hier etwas näher zu sein
jetzt konnte hier auch noch auf
neuronale jetzt zu sprechen der gemeinde
nächste mal ein bisschen darauf zu
sprechen dass mit ihr noch lesen das
letzte das letzte aber womöglich wichtig
aber wichtigste argument gegen den
versuch einer rechenmaschine
menschliches denken zu schreiben ist
folgendes wenn wir menschen einen denkt
vorgang bzw
theoretisch ist wie praktische
intelligenz zu schreiben dann
berücksichtigen wir nicht nur eine
vielfalt von mentaler geschafft ist und
auch intentionen also dass gerichtet
sein des geistes auf metzners diese
intention aber wird durch künstliche
neuronale sie nicht realisiert
das haben wir ja auch schon zu gut
da müssen gegeben sein aber er das nicht
jeder verheben schon einmal stimmt das
optimum angestrebt werden wälder und
gesagt diese doch dass die texterkennung
sehr schlecht sei irgendwo da muss ich
mit arbeiten widersprechen weil die
texterkennung von liebherr ist so gut
dass sie viele normale straßen
leistungsprämie stellt deutschland
übertreffen
also es ist die perle ist besser als ich
im licht und zwar bei sehr komplexen
spuren also bei der sprache intelligenz
in der spracherkennung ist doch schon
sehr erstaunlich was die menschen zuerst
ein wirklicher erfolg einem speicher mit
von intelligenz war die frage wie gesagt
nicht intelligenz definieren was
studierst du mir sagen sondern relativen
sinne dass wir jung kein eigenes
es sind damit meinen dass wir neben
datenbasis vorgesetzt bekommen dann kann
das gute aber flexibel sein weil man
muss einfach bedenken selten werden wird
die datenbasis so sein dass das nur
künstliche neuronale netz dieselben
sätze findet eins zu eins muss
kombinieren es muss erschließt wenn ich
daran setzte ein steuer sind dieses
system aus dem jahr 1800 dieser satz
wurde noch nie ins englische übersetzt
den gab es noch nie übersetzt den text
datengrundlage liefert diesem satz 1 1
nicht das heißt dass künftig die
netzwerk muss ich das selbst
rekonstruieren und es muss ein guter
sänger
es müssen regeln sehr clever auch
semantische oder syntaktische regelung
jedenfalls müssen ganz ganz clever
angewendet werden und dass das dann
deutlich was sinnvolles rauskommt auch
wenn natürlich gibt er nicht den sinn
steht
aber das versteht die syntax wie diese
sachen angeordnet werden müssen ist
damit schon so gut im interimszeit viel
geld weil so lernen die aussprache das
immer versuchen uns an ähnlichen system
zu orientieren und dann wird sich neue
sätze hervorbringen die wir zuvor noch
nie gehört und das ist ja da
sie wissen ja bei sorgen die wir schwer
übergibt selbst oder auch bei sprich
gehört haben da haben die homologierung
liegen autos kamen genau bei der partner
als nicht irgendein bei semantik ist es
leichter beim rat mag wird schwierig bei
mathematischen sein aber ich glaube es
wurde vor einiger zeit dass wir diese
daten um leute so erweitern dass auch
eine pragmatisch dimension oder die
ironische definition mit der fraktion
auch wenn man natürlich sagen kann gebe
es nicht alkoholisiert war
aber ihr geht es nicht um algorithmen
der wechsel geht es um zahlen er geht es
um erfahrungswerte um ein spiegel
prozesse und musste erkennen und da bin
ich also noch ganz offen
und hier müssen wir jetzt die diskussion
abbrechen wir werden in der nächsten
sitzung noch einmal auf diese these von
einem reinen eingeben und dann uns immer
mehr raucher mit ethischen
fragestellungen im kontext dieser
problematik künstler musikgeschäft dann
bis zum nächsten sitzt